اما النجاه او الهلاك هذا كان العنوان
الابرز في قمه المناخه المنعقده في شرم
الشيخ اليوم التي توافد اليها قاده العالم
لبحث اكبر خطر يهدد البشريه التغير
المناخي الجميع اجمع على خطوره الازمه
المناخيه واثارها الكارثيه على البشر
والارض وهنا يكمن التحدي سرعه التحرك
التعاون والجهد المشترك من الجميع فالوقت
يداهمنا والهدف الاول والاهم خفض درجه
حراره الكوكب لاننا في معركه بقاء اما
ننجو معا او تقودنا للهلاك
[موسيقى]
و خلال قمه المناخ وجه الامين العام للامم
المتحده تحذيرا جديده
ان مشكله المناخ تمثل معركه خطيره ضد
الانسانيه
اون لاين
في مواجهه التغير المناخي ونحن نخسر
ارتفاع درجات الحراره حول العالم مستمر
والخطر كبير الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراعات
واعمال العنف القت بظلالها على العالم يجب
الا نركز فقط على حل الصراعات وننسى مشكله
المناخ لان المناخ يمثل تحديا كبيرا لنا
الفوضى المناخيه هي السبب الرئيسي في
الصراعات العالميه الحرب على البيئه
انتهاك خطير لحقوق الانسان هناك تحذيرات
علميه من حقيقه ارتفاع درجات الحراره ما
يعني اننا نقترب من نقطه لا عوده
ومن شرم الشيخ اطلق ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان مبادره الشرق الهوسط
الاخضر واعلن ان المملكه ستخصص اثنين 0 5
مليار دولار من اجل مبادره خضراء بالشرق
الاوسط على مدار السنوات العشر القادمه
وستضيف مقرها الرئيسي واكدا في الوقت ذاته
على استهداف السعوديه الوصول الى الحياد
الصفري في عام 2050